[موسيقى]
آية هي أكثر من تجربة بسيطة
من المفترض أن تكون آية
قابلة للتحقيق للغاية ولا توجد مجموعة سكانية محددة كما
تعلم، خذ كل شيء في الخبرة
التي أعتقد أنها يمكن أن تخلق السحر لأي
شخص في أي عمر
[موسيقى]
آية  Universe عبارة عن تجربة تبلغ مساحتها 40000 قدم مربع تم
بناؤها عبر 12 منطقة باستخدام
أنواع مختلفة من التكنولوجيا في
المساحات، لذلك كل شيء بدءًا من رسم خرائط الإسقاط
إلى الحدائق المضيئة بيولوجيًا المضاءة
بالألياف الضوئية إلى أنظمة المحتوى الفريدة التي
تتضمن مساحات مرآة لا متناهية وإسقاطات LED
ومساحات تفاعلية
[موسيقى]
المفضل لدي  هي لورا فلورا عبارة عن
حديقة ذات إضاءة حيوية مكونة من 750000
شريط من كابلات الألياف الضوئية
[موسيقى]
من حيث إنشاء المحتوى أود أن أقول إن
إحدى الغرف المفضلة هي الشلالات
وهي شلال مقلوب
حيث يتدفق الماء إلى أعلى
الهارمونيا  وهو نظام إضاءة DMX يتم التحكم فيه بواسطة الروبوت
وهو غرفة شائعة جدًا
أيضًا، Luna هي أكثر
غرفة صور لدينا على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي.
تم تأسيس الفضاء الفائق [الموسيقى] في أواخر عام
2020، لذلك كنا نعمل منذ ما يزيد
قليلاً عن عامين  ومكاننا الأول
الذي افتتحناه هو Iowa Universe في
Waukee City، حيث
كنا نتطلع إلى خلق المزيد من
الانسيابية بين
أنماط الحياة الرقمية والمادية، سواء كان ذلك من خلال
الأصول الرقمية المميزة، فهذه
كلها عناصر نسحبها إلى
منتزهنا ومن ثم بالنسبة لنا  نحن
نعيش إلى حد كبير في مستقبل
تكنولوجيا النماذج الأولية التي تجمع بين التقنيات الجديدة
في المساحات وهذا نوع من الطريقة التي
نحافظ بها على أهميتنا كشركة
مايا تحيط بك حقًا في كل
سياق في تجربة حسية زائدة كاملة
عندما تكون بالداخل،
فهي تفاعلية بشكل مثير ولكن  إنه في الواقع
يشمل الجسم بطريقة
تجعلك تشعر وكأنك تسافر إلى
عالم بعيد جدًا، وتشعر بذلك حقًا
عندما تغادر آية وأنت
تجلس في سيارتك تقود على طريق سريع
وفجأة تجد نفسك  'نتذكر هذا
النوع من الوجود الرفيع
[موسيقى]